is zumato a genie how do you pick the
right restaurant
when you want to go out with your
friends
[Music]
by looking at the ratings and reviews on
zumato right
have you ever wondered how your cousin
can name so many exotic dishes
it's probably the courtesy of sumatra's
customer recommendations
how do you satisfy sudden cravings for
chinese food at home
you order food right chances are that
one out of the two times you order food
online you order from zamato
didn't you notice zamato appears like a
genie
every time you think about food but
what's the story behind zumato
and how did it become a hunger genie
meet deepinder goyal the genie maker
like many regular office goers he would
eat meals at the office pantry
the thing that annoyed him the most was
long queues
cues for deciding what to order cues for
tables
and cues for picking up the food
the story was similar even at local
eateries
people did not even know what was
available at the restaurants before they
visited them
the entire system of ordering food was
inefficient
and boring dipinder wanted to fix this
as they say if necessity is a mother of
invention
empathy is a mother of great ideas
deepinder's empathy gave him a genius
idea
the first thing that he wished to do was
give people
access to the menus of the restaurants
so he decided to visit every restaurant
in his vicinity
to collect their food menus and create a
directory
and he did this during weekends or after
office hours
deepinder started figuring out the best
way to make this information
available to all users at their
fingertips
and that's when he launched
foodiebay.com
not only did the site have the menu
directory it also became a go-to site
for foodies and bloggers
it hosted hundreds of menus and reviews
of eating joints
with recommendations what could food
ebay do with this information
two things it could help the users make
an informed choice
and it could help the restaurants
improve their services
foodie bay was a hit and the founders
decided to make it bigger
and better so foodie bay
became samato in 2010.
over the years sumato added a lot of
features to their platform
take a moment and go through all of them
sumato's vision is pretty clear now
better food
for more people as of 2020 zamato is
valued at over
3.5 billion us dollars
isn't it amazing to see how a small
empathy based idea
grew into a mammoth revenue generating
business
zomato made a revenue of close to 400
million dollars
in the financial year 2020 and it
generates revenues
mainly through the following things
restaurant listings
food delivery commissions subscription
or loyalty programs
and by providing kitchen infrastructure
services
notice the flow of events in the zumata
story
it all began with empathy after which
the problem was defined
then the founders came up with the idea
to fix the problem
after which the idea was validated by
the users
as well as the restaurant owners
once these things are in place it's all
about execution i'm sure
you will think of the zumata story every
time you see the long queues for any
service
or a need to collate information and
present it
or when reviews or feedback are needed
or when something needs to be delivered
are there other interesting things you
know about sumato
do tell us in the comment section below
and don't forget to visit the endpower
website to learn more about
entrepreneurship happy learning
empower is running the third season of
india's future tycoons
nationwide platform for 13 to 17 year
olds
to showcase their entrepreneurial skills
if you're interested please register for
free on their website